le secteur hyper centre de saint quentin
en yvelines va être réaménagé pour ce
projet un groupement multidisciplinaire
de professionnels de l'urbanisme a
besoin des habitants et usagers pour
dessiner le projet qui répondra le plus
à leurs besoins l'objectif c'est arrivé
un aménagement durable qui créer de
l'attractivité de l'animation ce secteur
à l'image de saint quentin à l'image de
la ville de montigny
voilà c'est un secteur central qui
représente et qui ont pour l'heure été
importante sur le secteur
après une balade urbaine pour pointer
les problématiques des lieux le mois
dernier cet atelier permettait aux
habitants de débattre et de faire des
propositions sur trois thématiques les
usagers déplacement la nature en ville
et l'identité général souhaitait pour le
quartier j'attends surtout qu'on a mais
les ovations sur le déplacement dans la
comen mettre un peu de 2me nature
verdure au à des hongrois bien
spécifiques
c'est hyper important de
pouvoir nous consulter nous les
habitants ce je pense que c'est la
première fois que je vois ça et la
manière dont c'est fait c'est atelier
les visites etc
je trouve ça génial les cartes sont
agrémentés de pictogrammes indiquant les
lieux et la nature des problèmes et une
grande roue réunit les idées et volonté
d'aménagement pour les trois thématiques
abordées ces plans plus se trouve
fabrique un peu pour nous le programme
de départs ce qu'elle va commencer à
dessiner l'espace pour deux ateliers de
ce type ont eu lieu dans la journée un
dernier se tiendra le 29 février pour
une restitution du travail des habitants